hey guys welcome back to the second
video of today and today is going to be
focused on the shinobi the second
character of season 2 like I said in the
last video we're going to be going over
their move sets show off their outfits
then I'll give you my personal opinion
on them as a first impression also I
will be doing these characters you know
kind of experimenting them later getting
them to rep one - then give you a better
opinion on if they're worth playing or
not or if they're worth the 15 steel as
of my opinion now let's get into this
because it's a very complex move set so
Rocha has Orochi holy [ __ ] shinobi has a
[ __ ] ton of chains the shadow dancer
sickle rain ghouls rage and the spider
silk with I will show off these three
and then move on to the sickle rings
last so the shadow dancers are basic
light attack like light the ghouls
they're the ghouls rage is the heavy and
then [ __ ] me it'd be heavy and then RB
which is a light and the spider silk is
a double heavy now the huge complex one
the silk the sickle rain is a poisonous
one and it's probably one of the longest
combos I've ever seen it's a double
heavy and a triple light which looks
like this it basically applies bleed for
most of the attacks which is kind of
like peacekeeper in a way oh my god my
goodness but anyway he also has a tackle
and a super sprint which I'll show all
if none of you have watched it the
shinobi has one of these cool little
interesting moves where he does a super
sprint which is double the speed but at
the cost of stamina where he puts his
arms or his arms behind his back and
chases opponents but you can also go and
do a tackle move which works in both
modes which will go underneath them and
tackle the opponent from probably a free
hit well like I said I've barely touched
these characters I've only just started
using them from
the tutorial here so I've no clue if any
of this is even viable yet you can also
charge the heavy attack which is one of
the more better mix-ups in the game you
can charge this and then go into combos
you can also fake the charge and press
the guard break button do a guard break
and lean your character in which is the
grab the sickle rain mix-up is the is a
very complicated bleed and unblockable
attack that I'm going to attempt for the
first time here let's see if I can land
this there we go so let's try that one
more time throw that down let's back up
go charge the heavy which is holding the
right trigger or the heavy button go for
the guard break while you're holding it
RT and then triple a triple light I kind
of [ __ ] up again I apologize this [ __ ]
is very difficult to pull off here's a
lot of moves that revolve around a kick
which I have yet to figure out what that
is well all I can sit the only thing I
can find out about a kick is a double
dash which is the double tapping the
dash button and then X which is this
which I believe is the only kick that so
that at least makes sense to me so we
can do the double tap a which is all the
way down here which is the kick the
double tap a and then guard break which
will probably lean into these attacks so
let's try the heavy attack first [ __ ]
are there you go and then we'll try the
dash
and then do a guard break there you go
all right oh this is insanely difficult
to pull off he also has a back flip move
which is the light attack heavy attack
or light attack or heavy attack and then
tapping afterwards so for example light
attack or heavy attack I just have to do
is go move backwards and press a so if
you're in a shitty situation just kind
of backup not liking the outcome just
kind of keep backing up you can also do
multiple other moves like this for
example we will do and pull off these
two so we'll do light backup and then a
heavy so the heavy backup another heavy
and then we'll do light backup - and
then X I can even pull this off there
you go all right this these moves look
so stupid when I'm trying to pull this
off because this character has such
complex move set the mood he probably
has the biggest move set out of every
character in this whole game that's why
it's super difficult for me to pull
these moves off so I apologize but like
I said after the rep after I play some
duels with them I will show you my
better opinion on them I'm just showing
you what they look like for today he's
got a bunch of dashing moves such as the
double dodged the double dodged kick
double applaud double dodged light and
double dodged heavy which I'll show here
is the double dodged is kind of like a
smoke and mirrors thing dodge and then a
kick is the guard break double dodged
and then light and double dodged and a
heavy super simple then I got the other
two moves he has the to deflect moves
which is the deflect and then to a guard
break which kind of kicks the character
back he also has the guard Brit or the
deflect into a guaranteed light and they
also the parry into a guaranteed light
which is a bleeding attack now you have
to remember that if you run all the
stamina you can actually not charge this
heavy attack so most your combos will
not work
anyway I'm just going to go show you
guys the outfits and then we will and
then I will come will come resume back
and I will tell you my honest opinion of
the character as a first impression
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that was kind of cool the outfits
really do look nice for the characters I
said this in the last video that the
devs really did a good job on what the
characters look like making them all
look nice and [ __ ] but in my honest
opinion I like shinobi he's really cool
great mix ups very very complex moves
yet
I don't know if I'm going to be using a
lot him a lot as as opposed to Centurion
but in honestly though he did he can be
a very deadly force which is probably
why they gave him the three and a half
bars of health to compensate for how
quick he is anyway like I said before I
hope you guys did enjoy and the next
week or two hopefully before the season
the Nantes and pass owners get this
video did B characters I'm going to make
a video on these guys kind of showing if
these characters are worth the 15 K
steel or not anyway boys I hope you guys
did enjoy and I will see you actually on
Thursday for the dev stream so peace out
boys and have a great day